chaos in Nigeria's capital near me
cars and buildings are looted and set
Ablaze near the headquarters of the
ruling party
outside the National Assembly supporters
of the cool celebrate
they backed the presidential Guard
soldiers who unseated the president on
Wednesday and upload the Army's decision
to support the coup
Les
we always believed in the Army despite
conditions that have tried to
destabilize it we believe that the Army
by taking power will create the
conditions for the Army to regain its
values
a group of soldiers appeared on
television blaming Muhammad bazoom for a
deteriorating security situation and
economic mismanagement
the interior Ministry has banned all
demonstrations with immediate effect
an unstable ninja however could further
destabilize the Sahel region and the
fight against armed groups linked to
Al-Qaeda and isil I think the bigger
concern is that these jihadist groups
will also have an opportunity to not
only expand their activity further into
Nigeria but also connect with other
jihadist groups that are on the other
side of Niger so we're talking Isis
Olivia or the Islamic West Africa and
Boko Haram or even so far as other
groups across the region in East Africa
the African Union France the United
States Germany Russia and the United
Nations have all called for the
immediate release of President Bazoo I
spoke yesterday with president bazum
I don't know exactly where he is but it
was detained
he told me it was well
but he told me that the situation was
very serious
as bazoom remains detained the battle
for power continues Ahmed Idris Al
Jazeera